Film Courage: So switching gears a little
bit, I was wondering if you can take us back
to where you were in your life when you switched
careers? You were a basketball player for
awhile. I know you grew up in the music business
with your dad but then you played basketball.
And then there was a point where you switched
careers? Can you talk about mentally where
you were, physically where you were? How was
that? Harvey Mason, Jr.: Yeah, when I was
playing basketball my dream was to play in
the NBA and I had a career-ending injury which
kind of made me change direction and focus
or re-focus on music. And that was a tough
time because I really planned on playing basketball
and I worked my whole life to do that. But
in the long run I think it was a really fortunate
turn of events. To get hurt, you never think
it’s a good thing, but it turned me toward
music and it made me really, really take all
my energy and effort that I was putting into
basketball and put it toward music. That was
right at the time I finished college. So I
was young and I was still malleable enough
to adjust and switch into something else.
But music was always a passion of mine when
I was a kid. I think I started taking piano
lessons when I was 6 years old or 7 years
old and it was a hobby all through college.
I always kept my toe in the water with music.
And then when basketball finished for me,
it was just definitely kind of a wholesale
refocusing. I started doing jingles locally
in Arizona where I was going to college. I
started doing commercial music and working
for ad agencies. And I was doing music for
anybody who wanted it. Brake stores, buses,
things like that. I would make a jingle for
anybody. And all the while I was trying to
get to Los Angeles to kind of kick in somebody’s
door to listen to my music. That took me probably
three or four years driving out to LA for
a week at a time, trying to get people to
listen to my demos. I was sending cassettes
to people back then, throwing cassettes into
people’s convertibles, doing anything I
could to get my music heard and that was kind
of how I started here in LA was just driving
out here. Sleeping in my car every now and
then, whatever I had to do. And then one guy
took notice. He said “Hey I love what you
do. I’ll pay you (I think) $2,500.00 to
do a job for me.” and at that point I was
like “Oh my God! I’m in. I made it.”
And that was my first job. Motown Records.
I did a remix for one of their artists. And
then I ended up here doing an interview with
you. Film Courage: What year was this? Harvey
Mason, Jr.: That was probably 1990….1994?
Something like that. Film Courage: You said
earlier that you take a nugget of something
from each project and that there is [always]
some lesson in it. So looking back at the
jingles…maybe creatively it wasn’t the
most fulfilling, maybe it was? What did you
take from this [time working on jingles] that
you then used to build this amazing studio
that you have here which is absolutely beautiful.
Harvey Mason, Jr.: I’ll tell you, I took
so much from that two or three year period
where I did advertising music because you
have to do every range of music. If some guy
says “Well I want it to be country western
and my burger joint, I feel like it’s a
country place or…blues music or I want this
kind of a music or I want classical.” You
have to be able to do all that type of music.
You have to be able to deliver it quickly
and you have to be able to do it economically
when you’re working in a small market like
that so it was an amazing training ground
for me. The other thing that I got from that
was working outside of your own bubble of
creativity. Like you can’t do whatever you
want. When this guy is trying to sell cars
with his music. You have to do whatever he
thinks is going to sell cars. So you really
have to pay attention to what people want.
You have to be able to translate what they’re
thinking because a car salesman or a break
store owner or a guy who runs a mall is not
a musician. You have to figure out what he’s
trying to get to with his music and figure
out how to get it out of your fingers and
out of the speakers ultimately. That is what
I use everyday whether it is an A & R guy
for a record label or a director for a film.
Being able to take what they say and they
think and what they feel and making that come
to life with music is something that I do
every day. So that is great training. And
as I said, being able to do all the different
kind of genres of music and being able to
have access to my background being in all
those types of music. I did so many rock n’
roll commercials, so many classical commercials
that I can draw from when I’m needing to
do a piece of music for a film. Question for
the Viewers: What was your first job in the
entertainment business?